how's it going everyone it's Warren and
today we're going to talk about
something that I've been wondering about
for a very long time now and something
that I've wanted to see for a very long
time now and that is Agent Coulson
returning in an Avengers film it was a
huge shock when they killed him in the
very first Avengers film especially with
the way they built up his character and
then it was an even bigger shock when
they brought him back in Marvel's agents
of shield and with him returning an
agents of shield and with agents of
shield beam in the MCU happening
alongside with everything that happens
in the Marvel films I think everybody
expected him to make some sort of an
appearance in some MCU films
particularly in an Avengers film or in a
Captain America film but surprisingly we
have not seen him in an MCU film yet
which is odd because agents of shield
references things that happen inside of
the MCU and there even have been a few
characters from the MCU films that have
appeared in agents of shield but since
Avengers endgame is most likely going to
involve time travel and flashbacks
people are starting to wonder if we're
going to see Agent Coulson and during a
recent interview Clark Gregg who plays
Agent Coulson was asked if he would
appear in Avengers in game in which he
teased us by saying in the world of
Marvel anything's possible a pretty big
tease considering that it doesn't really
answer the question but it does make
sense that he would return especially
after the snap and Avengers Infinity
Ward now that Nick Fury and agent Hill
are gone it would make sense that Agent
Coulson would come into play plus
Avengers in game is supposed to wrap up
the story arc from the first ten years
of the MCU and he played a pretty big
part in the beginning and in the first
Avengers film so it would be really nice
to see him reunite with Tony
Steve and all of the rest of the
Avengers for one last time and again he
could play a relatively significant role
in Avengers in game given his current
position as of right now looks like
we're going to have to wait till April
when the movie comes out to find out but
let me know what you think do you think
Agent Coulson will make a return in
Avengers end game and if so do you think
it will be in a flashback or do you
think Agent Coulson will help play a
part in trying to undo that as a snap
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below
and don't forget I'm still doing my
giveaway giving away five imax tickets
if you'd like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is subscribe
to my
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain as always thank you
all so much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]
you